voilà pour les molières bonsoir et
isabelle adjani je suis très content je
vois tourner très content de vous voir
parce qu'on vous l'a rarement notamment
dans un journal télévisé
alors vous venez pas ce que vous allez
nous parler d'un disque que vous avez
commencé à tourner clic comme on dit
demain demain ça va s'appeler princesse
au petit pois
oui c'est le titre vedette du 45 tours
oui et c'est vous qui avez fait le tacle
c'est moi qui ai créé par louis bon et
les la musique c'est sébastien santa
maria celui qui avait fait lui magie
alors la première question que je vous
pose et sait comment allez vous écouter
et vous non je dis ça vous savez vous
pas ça parce que sur une radio on a
entendu très récemment que vous étiez
hospitalisé alors vous avez tout de
suite démenti mais il ya eu un grain
quelque chose oui c'est s'est produit
avant-hier
écoutez c'est simple imaginez que vous
trouvez dans votre voiture à 18 heures
que vous vous dirigez vers ici pour
présenter le journal télévisé et vous
entendez les informations 18 heures on
annonce que vous êtes est hospitalisé
imaginez deux secondes
l'effet que ça peut produire sur sur vos
amis sur votre famille et puis sur vous
même et c'est tout à fait terrible et
c'est quand même très dommage que en ce
moment l'information se basent un tout
petit peu trop sur des rumeurs c'est à
dire que moi je trouve que l'information
est une chose adultes qui est fait par
des gens professionnels et que c'est
très dommage quand des journalistes ou
d'un coup discrédite leur collègue en
faisant ce que j'appelle une bavure
c'est à dire en ne faisant pas leur
métier et en annonçant des choses qu'ils
auraient pu très simplement vérifier
suffisait de nous téléphoner de passe un
coup de fil
non on va pas citer de noms mais on va
pas non plus généraliser ce volet savoir
quand même vous avez été absent depuis
un moment ça fait longtemps qu'on vous a
pas vu que vous avez fait ces derniers
temps
écoutez j'ai écrire des paroles d'une
chanson ça prend beaucoup de temps
ben là j'ai écrit deux chansons puisque
ces deux chansons le 45 tours et puis je
m'occupe beaucoup d'un
d'un projet qui me tient à coeur depuis
deux ans sur lequel je travaille je me
bats même depuis un an c'est le projet
de camille claudel qui nous raconte
c'est un projet de film pour raconter
pour faire la vie l'histoire de camille
claudel cissé à camille claudel était un
sculpteur très extraordinaire qui a
passé une grande partie de sa vie avec
rodin et puis qui a terminé très mal
parce que son arles un petit peu
emporter des portes et vous vous êtes
intéressé au sort de ce sculpteur parce
que c'est un d'abord j'adore les vies
réelles j'adore les personnages qui ont
réellement existé je trouve que on peut
faire un travail profond sur en se
servant de son vécu et c'est un
personnage qui n'attire parce que elle
s'est beaucoup beaucoup inspiré de la
relation amoureuse qu'elle avait un
creux d'un pur pour faire pour sculpter
et puis c'était une grande artiste et
puis c'est quelqu'un qui a subi des
déboires pendant toute sa vie pendant
toute sa carrière parce que le talent ne
va pas sans la bêtise vous a
l'impression que la création ou le
talent a besoin de relations mot
justement de passion je crois oui je
crois qu'il faut c'est ça nourrit et que
plus et nourrit mieux ça vaut même si la
douleur
tu es parti de l'aboutissement de la
création isabelle adjani on vous a aussi
retrouvé dans le magazine globe avec
harlem désir est là c'était aussi un
petit peu une révélation parce que
d'abord vous avez dit je me suis
toujours sentie beurre alors on pouvait
ne pas savoir que votre père est
algérien et puis vous avez dit que vous
aviez envie de vous engager maintenant
ça veut dire quoi ça elle ment gâcher ça
veut d'abord dire revendiquait ce que je
suis revendiquer ce que je suis pour
aider les gens qui sont plus défavorisés
que moi à exister
alors ça peut se traduire par énormément
de choses
moi j'ai rencontré harlem désir et je
lui ai demandé qu'est ce que je peux
faire pour toi qu'est-ce que je peux
faire pour vous qu'est-ce que je peux
faire pour le mouvement qu'est ce que je
peux faire
chi x concrets qui est une véritable qui
est un véritable sens un véritable
impact et ça on va travailler tous les
deux pour l'instant je prête mon nom
mais j'espère bien donner un peu plus de
ma personne que mon
merci d'avoir été notre invité votre
disque sort quand ils sortent dans une
dizaine de chevaux
voilà merci beaucoup il avait la donne
et on va voir la météo avec brigitte
simonetta